a lot of people are doing Instagram
lives like constantly and I have some
notes I have some thoughts I have some
constructive feedback because it's um
it's a lot I think the first thing I
would say is what are you looking at
pick a spot every time someone gets at
Instagram live the first thing you do is
they look at themselves for the first
minute they're like hey guys you're
supposed to look in the cool of the
camera you're not supposed to look at
yourself in fact so I just spit on me
all over myself we didn't join your live
to watch you check yourself out look
they're there the first minute someone
gets on Instagram live they're mostly
just spiraling about their appearance
you'll see someone get on Instagram live
and they're like hey guys hey what's up
guys how's it going how's your
quarantine going you guys good or you
don't just wait to talk about the
pandemic till you're done checking out
your lip gloss it's a lot of wild angles
these angles are just a lot there's a
lot of like hey everyone hi hey guys I'm
doing a live I'm doing an Instagram live
hey everyone hey check it in what's up
guys hey I'm doing alive you guys good
what's up what's going on everyone how
are you
you guys good what's up hey girl square
up pick up pick a set pick a background
keep it simple a lot of these
instruments are people just reading the
comments they're just like hey Lilly oh
my gosh you're so ready hey Lisa oh
thanks I just got it thanks hey Mindy
how's it going I know it looks better
short right it's always funny to see
celebrities skip a negative
but still internalized it like you'll
see a celebrity be like oh thank you um
thank you guys I know I just want to do
as many Instagram lives as possible to
stay connected with you guys thank you
know it's the least I can do thank you
oh thank you thank you I'm not even
wearing any makeup thank you um so what
else should we talk about like they just
saw someone called them a dumb whore I'd
really take a look at your background
make sure it doesn't clash with the
climate we're currently in I'm seeing a
lot of wooden art with inspirational
quotes I'm seeing like pieces of
driftwood on people's walls that says
like don't ask for a light load ask for
a strong back we're in a pandemic we're
gonna need more than that don't try to
learn how to weather the storm try to
figure out how to dance in the rain it's
an invisible virus quotes are it's a
wrap on quotes quotes are canceled
inspirational quotes are canceled what
we need is a vaccine when did I start
holding this so aggressively I got it's
not doing these alone you guys this is
getting bad don't worry I washed my
hands I washed my hands there I'm gonna
do it like this from now on
I'm just doing my podcasts into an
actual Clorox wipe at this point which
by the way that's gonna make me get high
I just got dizzy don't inhale those that
close whoa gonna open this soon
can't wait it get inside my body
love you